was macht eigentlich die afd in dieser
corona krise
sagen wir mal so in den ersten tagen da
war die alternative ja fast schon
erschreckend staatstragend unterwegs
inzwischen haben sie aber wohl zur alten
form zurückgefunden als gelernte angst
vampire saugen sie die wut und den frust
der bürger auf heute sind natürlich
sämtliche groner maßnahmen für die afd
mindestens ddr 2.0 wissen sie was sie
damit den bürgern dieses land ist antun
sie erzeugen angst history und
depression angst hysterie und depression
das ist immer noch das kerngeschäft der
afd
aktuell profitiert die partei in
umfragen nicht von der krise aber machen
wir uns nichts vor das kann sich mit
zunehmender rezession natürlich noch
ändern
gleichzeitig erlebt die afg aber eine
schwere zerreißprobe
der vorstand hat andreas kalbitz dem
brandenburger afg chef wegen seiner
rechtsextremen vergangenheit die
parteimitgliedschaft entzogen ein
paukenschlag
aber ich werde daran die holt sich die
zurück denn zurückholen ist quasi vor
sein ding holen wir uns gemeinsam und
zwar zurück wir holen uns dieses land
zurückgeholt zurück
und deutschland zurück vorhersagen
zurück obwohl er erst mal die gewalt
über deine zunge zurück kallwitz in der
afc trugen jetzt offene flügelkämpfe und
es ist wirklich muss man sagen eine
völlig ungewohnte situation für uns alle
sonst haben uns immer amerikaner oder
engländer entnazifiziert jetzt mtv ziert
sich eine deutsche partei selber und
schreibt damit geschichte
[Musik]
und so history mit serdar somuncu 2020
die staunende deutsche öffentlichkeit
erlebt einen der erbärmlichsten
putschversuche der deutschen geschichte
ein bislang völlig unbekannter linker
flügel der afd
ergreift die macht im parteivorstand
antifaschistische kräfte um jörg merten
und die linksaktivisten beatrix von
storch versuchen andreas kalbitz aus der
partei zu drängen ja der kalbitz
strahlender sieger von brandenburg und
sieben jahre in folge gewinner des
heinrich himmler look alike contests
wird gnadenlos rausgemobbt für was nur
dafür dass er vor jahren mal bei einem
harmlosen lederhosen fetisch treffen von
irgendwelchen nazi pfadfindern dabei war
ich direkt scharf wenn ich sowas sehe
ist dass hier etwas schon extremismus
wer sind die totengräber der baulichen
reste dieser achtung sechs ersetzung und
die afg ist die letzte evolutionäre
chance für dieses land danach kommt nur
noch helm auf wir werden auf den gräbern
tanzen ja natürlich ist andreas kalbitz
genau so bürgerlich und der witz ist
bestimmt sogar übrigens haben sich die
beiden jahrelang 0 an dem gestört was
heimlichkeit wird so in die welt rückt
jetzt wo die beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz droht machen sie einen
auf antifa extrem glaubwürdig gerade bei
frau von storch wie war das damals noch
mit dem schießen an der grenze auf die
anfrage eines facebook users wollt ihr
etwa frauen mit kindern an der grünen
wie sie den zutritt mit waffengewalt
verhindern schrieb sie kurz und knapp ja
inzwischen ruderte sie halbherzig zurück
zumindest gegen kinder sei der
schusswaffengebrauch nicht zulässig nur
auf die mütter schießen so viel
sentimentalität hat heute keinen platz
mehr in der afd
deswegen ist auch völlig klar wie dieser
pseudo machtkampf rechts gegen ganz
rechts am ende ausgeht
stillgestanden es folgt eine ansage aus
dem bernburger wer die argumente von
partei gegnern aufgreift und die gegen
parteifreunde wendet der begeht verrat
glied wie bedrohlich im günstigsten fall
bleibt den beiden flitz bieten hier noch
das exil
angeblich gibt es aber schon ein angebot
von netflix für eine eigene serie von
storch um leuten sind nazi jäger in der
ard auf keinen fall gucken wird scheiße
gute nacht holten show history ja
it-service bruns ich spreche mit jürgen
wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben immer versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel ruhig auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung